my name is Glenn I'm 25 and I don't know
my real last name it's not uncommon in
America most black people in this
country are walking around with a
slave-owner his last name black history
has been systemically erased and altered
for centuries as I give this talk there
are more than 700 Confederate monuments
standing nationwide these were erected
to honor Confederate soldiers who fought
to maintain slavery mostly in the south
from the 1890s to the 1950s when Jim
Crow laws enforcing racial segregation
were in full effect to this day black
people are forced to confront monuments
of slaveholders in our public spaces
these memorials are a physical
representation of a system that is
actively working to define whose lives
matter and whose lives do not if we are
going to disrupt the narrative we have
to start at the origin genocide slavery
and patriarchy started in the Americas
with Christopher Columbus most people in
the United States know about his voyage
in 1492 fewer people know that an
estimated 250,000 indigenous era whacks
were wiped out within two years of his
arrival even fewer people know that
Columbus admitted in a letter in Cydonia
Juana de della Torres that nine and
ten-year-old girls were in high demand
and four girls of all ages a good price
must be paid yet
New York City's Columbus Circle has had
him perched 76 feet high next to Central
Park since 1892
I started movers and shakers a
non-profit to get this statue removed
movers and shakers is a group of
activists artists educators and
engineers
focused on using immersive technology to
highlight the narratives of the
oppressed and our campaign to knock
Columbus off his pedestal we engaged in
a visually provocative form of activism
we created an augment
reality installation on the true story
of Christopher Columbus and used it to
host teach-ins
in Columbus Circle and Times Square many
see the controversy around the statue as
tension between the italian-american
community and the indigenous community
the reality is that most black people
are here in this country as a result of
the atrocities that were kicked off by
Christopher Columbus so we ended up
holding a slave auction in Union Square
to tie in to the genesis of the
transatlantic slave trade I ran the New
York City Marathon in Chains to spread
awareness to this issue
I was also arrested in Giants Stadium
for hosting a slavery enactment at their
football team's home opener we gave it
everything that we had but in the end
New York City decided to keep the statue
and New York State unanimously voted to
make it a landmark the news was
devastating but it opened up another
door we realized that with augmented
reality you don't need permission from
the government to put up a monument or
to make a statement you can just do it
so New York City right now currently has
more than 150 statues of men and six of
women and currently acknowledges slave
holders in public spaces as well so we
decided why not just put up a bunch of
AR monuments of women and people of
color throughout the city typically
monuments are created to commemorate the
achievements of the deceased but with
augmented reality we can rewrite the
rules we started with sports colin
kaepernick he was the starting
quarterback at the San Francisco 49ers
and he wanted to use this platform to
highlight the injustice of systemic
racism so he consulted a green beret to
find out the most respectful way to do
this and he decided to take a knee
during the national anthem
he lost his contract with the 49ers he
was blackballed by every NFL owner he
was criticized by millions and even the
President of the United States decided
to insult him it may be decades before
Colin Kaepernick
is adequately respected for his courage
so our team decided to do this now
anyone that walks by Trump Tower can see
Colin Kaepernick take a knee in
augmented reality and there's nothing
that can do about it
representation matters Serena Williams
proved to the world that a black girl
from Compton can dominate a sport that's
traditionally played at exclusive
country clubs let's celebrate her now
Jackie Robinson he broke the color
barrier and empowered many black
athletes to play in Major League
Baseball we're going to take this
monument of him and put it in a bits
field so that anyone can see him swing
for the fences in Ebbets Field in
Brooklyn with augmented reality we have
the power to tell stories in public
spaces that need to be told the
achievements of people like Frida Kahlo
Audrey Lorde to say Louvre is your madam
CJ Walker this should be common
knowledge our vision is a Pokemon go for
a contextualized history augmented
reality can also be used as a tool to
support organizations that are fighting
against systemic oppression in 2019 we
will release our free smartphone app
with augmented reality monuments and
content you can take your smartphone and
hold it over any $1 bill and see a scene
in augmented reality that illustrates
the injustice of cash bail you can then
click on the screen and be directed to
the donation page of the bail project a
fund that raises money for people who
cannot afford bail with augmented
reality we the people have the power to
highlight the narratives of the
oppressed when institutions refuse to do
so we can use this tool to highlight the
systemic implications of erasing
someone's history and more concretely we
can use this technology as a way to
support initiatives that are fighting
against systemic racism with AR we have
the power to reimagine a world that
prioritizes justice
over oppression thank you
[Applause]